an aspect of all of this is
your safety oh i don't care about that
they want to kill me kill me
the head of army intelligence in 1992
when he found out what we were doing he
was so angry
and he says who hell do you think you
are i said well
i'm a free citizen of the earth and of
the cosmos and we're making contact he
says you're not cleared i said i don't
need your clearance or permission
so we went mano amano and i'm a nice guy
until you challenge me and i'm gonna lay
you out
and then i turned to him i said look
when i was 17 i died
i know there is no death i know that
what is within me and within all of us
goes on forever
and is infinite and eternal and
therefore
if you want to kill me go ahead but i'll
be more trouble to you on the other side
and he knows them
he knew he knew i was
right he knew i was right those people
understand that
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today you guys are in for a real treat
if you're ready to have your mind blown
just keep listening
because on the show is dr steven greer
he has
two documentaries out called
unacknowledged which came out a few
years ago and then one that just
recently came out
close encounters of the fifth kind he
also has an app called
ce5 that he talks about and refers to he
is a retired
trauma surgeon he was an er doctor and
he has dedicated his life to exposing
this aspect of reality that we have been
you know had the veil pulled over our
eyes on and has been hidden which is
extraterrestrials he has such an
awareness through his experiences and
curiosity of
consciousness um but then there's this
other side which extra
which is extraterrestrial and the thing
is is that
it's actually what it connects all of us
and that
we are all connected to a cosmic
consciousness like have you ever heard
of like the collective consciousness
that's what it is like we are all
connected not only are we connected on
this earth plane
here which is why you know a mother can
sense their child or when you think of
someone all of a sudden they call
we're connected to esther
extraterrestrial in the same way
so his life work is to bring this into
mainstream and to
save our planet right because we're on a
crash course right now in a lot of ways
and we have suppressed had
had the information and technology
suppressed for what can be brought
and offered to us from other forms of
reality in
in the universe because look we're like
five years
five years old i mean look what we can
do in ten years or a hundred years
and there are civilizations out there
that are
hundreds of thousands millions of years
older than us
so we have a lot to learn and we need to
get humble
and i really hope that you'll stay tuned
all the way to the end of this
fascinating conversation
with dr greer you know i was remembering
for some reason i had forgotten but when
i was watching i
watched close encounters of the fifth
kind when it first came out last year
and i was watching it again the other
night and i was remembering the story
i'm like
that's right when i was in fifth grade
i did a book report on close encounters
of the first
second and third kind oh really yeah
i mean this i mean so i'm 38 years old
so i was you know this is a long time
ago but
that's how long i have been interested
in reality
and what's real you get the time frame
of fifth grade that's a long time being
very interested in this world and i
remember being kid and also thinking of
space and thinking of you know infinity
and what's at the end of infinity
there's
there's got to be but if there's an end
then there's what's the
end look like and it would just give me
a headache so
how in the world so i'm rambling on but
because i'm so interested but also then
it brings me to
where i want you to help me out
it was like when i when i think of what
i want to ask
someone it tends to have
a flow and what really struck me
is just there's really two different
concepts that feel like they exist
for you which or at least two different
thoughts thought processes thought lines
and one has to do with consciousness
and our sovereign divinity
within the unity of unity consciousness
and the collective consciousness
right but then the other is
extraterrestrial activity
and the information underneath that so
instead of me trying to figure it out
would you please
help bridge the gap of how they connect
for you
well the way it connects for me and a
bit by people who haven't seen
um close encounters of the fifth kind
it's it's on amazon
prime and a bunch of and 2b in other
places now
so you can see it for free if you have
those um
that's sort of like a summary of what
happened from when i was about eight or
nine
where i had a sighting i was very young
like yourself got interested but i had a
daytime sighting
and uh with some my twin sister and some
people in the neighborhood and i went
wow and it was broad daylight crystal
clear this would have been 1963
or four and um i was really
amazed of course my parents saw we were
nuts and i
but i knew what i'd seen and so um and
then my uncle
you know the lunar module landed on the
moon with neil armstrong that was my
uncle
was the senior project engineer
designing the lunar module
so i had this real interest in space
anyway
and um i'm a medical doctor emergency
trauma shootings stabbings car wrecks
all the fun stuff
but i was like this is really
interesting
and then i sort of kind of forgot about
it um
when i became more adolescent but i was
fascinated from age eight or nine till
maybe
12 13. read everything i could
and then when i was 17 i died i had
i was very sick and had a near-death
experience
um and we were raised very left-brained
scientific reductionist
not religious uh not spiritual we just
you know if it didn't fit in a test tube
didn't exist
full stop so when i had this happen
i realized well my conscious being
is actually infinite and goes on forever
and i was because i loved space instead
of
you know seeing some religious themed
event
i went into outer space that's where i
was in my near-death experience and i
actually saw it experienced it
uh out of body as it were and it was a
beautiful
experience i mean i just like literally
went into this state of sort of cosmic
consciousness
and and i didn't know what that was
because i was not raised with any
understanding of
the soul or the spirit or consciousness
or infinity
so i said you know i really need to
learn how to meditate
i survived obviously because here i am
and
what i decided was that i really need to
learn how to get to that state of
samadhi or consciousness or higher
consciousness without dropping dead
right
and so i learned meditation and then
uh went off to college i was 17 when i
had the near-death experience so i'm 18
in the fall of 1973 and i'm meditating
up on a mountain in the blue ridge
mountains
and right before sunset that same e.t
craft that i had seen
when i was eight or nine reappeared
exactly
and just before sunset i went holy crap
this is amazing
and then it just vanished i said oh well
they're gone
so i sat and meditated and at the i had
this amazing meditation
and it was way you know an hour or two
it got dark
and at the end of it i
sort of came out of the deep meditative
state and looked around
and i saw the milky way above my head
we're up at over 5000 feet i was by
myself
and i sort of realized you know what a
beautiful universe
that's been made and created that's
conscious all of it is conscious
and i saw the stars and everything as
pure consciousness
becoming those things is beautiful and
at that moment
a little e.t well
little compared to me i'm 6'4 and 230
pounds but
an athlete so he appeared right beside
me and touched me on my right shoulder
and i had this amazing story uh event
that happened and that's
how we created the close encounters of
the fifth kind
uh protocol what we call ce5 contact and
there's an app that people can get
called ce5 contact that trains people
to do the meditation and make the
contact and i've written now i was too
young at age 18
i was just turned 18 to understand why
that worked
but then i became a meditation teacher
back in the day louise hay was a student
of mine and then subsequently jim carrey
and
deepak chopra all these people got
involved but
it was before i went to medical school
and i thought and i studied really
scientifically meditation brainwave
activity
as well as the sort of what people call
metaphysical part
but what i realized was that the physics
of consciousness was very well known
even back then in the in the early
mid 70s and that the consciousness field
is actually unbounded and is embedded
within
every point in space and time and there
have been experiments that had proven
that even back then now there's more
experimental
evidence for that is from dr john at
princeton you know we've referred to
these in the
documentary close encounters of the
fifth kind
but i didn't understand that from a left
brain point of view
intellectual point of view when i had
the experience but then i discovered
that
and then i understood why and how the
ets had made contact
because those civilizations you know we
have these things called
cell phones and it's really rubbish
isn't it i mean it's like from 1844
the electromagnetic signals are 170
years old it's rubbish
i'm so fascinated by uh
the story and wish i hope you can share
more
on like what exactly happened and what
information came
through when you had that meditative
experience where you
had an encounter and when you were
present
with an et what else can you share
well one thing i learned which was i
didn't understand
scientifically we understand it now we
touch on in the documentary close
encounters of the fifth kind
is that these civilizations which are
hundreds of thousands to
millions of years more advanced than we
are have pretty much
perfected what elon musk is trying to do
with neural link where he has a
company trying to figure out how you can
think to your computer
and it does things without wires now as
you
know dr john at princeton had
experimental
electronic devices that people could
think to and they would react
uh to the thought and this has been very
well reproduced all over the world
what these civilizations have are
extremely accurate
interfaces with consciousness and
directed thought that pick up the
thought as clearly as you and i are
talking on this
electromagnetic signal so that's how
that whole
event happened it was all based in
consciousness and thought now
that sounds like something way out there
except when you start talking to people
at the cia
like dr dr russell targ who's a laser
physicist for lockheed
who for 20 years was at the cia doing
consciousness studies
using consciousness to spy on the soviet
union so everyone thinks that this is
very fringe it isn't it's only fringe
because the mainstream media
ridicules it but in reality everyone at
a senior level of the intelligence
community knows this is real
so i stumbled across it and then i
realized that
these guys these et civilizations have
that ability
but i didn't understand how it worked it
was all kind of a mystery to me
at age 18. subsequently though i
realized that
the reason they were wanting me to
understand it was
i guess they figured because i had had
some kind of siding and contact and
interest
in them but i was also experiencing
these
higher states of consciousness that
maybe they could
you know develop something with me as a
young
man 18 year old guy where i could use it
to set up and educate the public about
making contact now that was in 1973
i didn't do anything with it for a long
time because i didn't know what to do
with it until 1990
and we started the ce5 contact protocols
which now of course we have hundreds of
thousands of people around the world
doing it but
um it was quite a journey for me as a
young boy
you know doing that and as you know like
um
last summer demi lovato and her friends
on her birthday had the ce5 contact app
and they were practicing it and they had
this amazing
e.t craft come over they all saw it was
very exciting
and they put it on instagram so what i'm
trying to do is have people
understand that you don't have to be
some kind of you know
yuri geller or mystic or
cie remote viewer to do this every
single person
who's conscious and awake can connect to
that quiet state of mind and do this
because these civilizations if you're
doing this with the right
attitude let's say in philosophy and
you're not
you know afraid and all that kind of
silly things they're going to pick that
up
and something will happen not every time
but they're very interested in humans
going into this sort of new
understanding of the cosmos
where we realize we and the cosmos
are awake and we're all sort of part of
this conscious
hologram known as reality and that's
really what they want us to understand
because that's the foundation
of becoming interstellar and and our
civilization is at the brink
of going from a tribalistic warring
civilization
to an interplanetary one but to do that
you have to have some foundation in
uh understanding what is the point where
we have something common
well it's not our own humanity that's
humanism because these are not humans
it has to be something more transcendent
deeper and that's this conscious field
that's universal this is you call
universal consciousness or cosmic
consciousness
and that they understand very well it's
not just a philosophy it's actually an
operating system like your computer as
an operating system
this understanding of cosmic
consciousness and
the fact that the universe is a
conscious
hologram where everything's connected to
each other
and like in physics in a hologram that
they understand but they also know that
we have to only understand it and it'll
actually begin to
actually you know walk that talk what is
our
role in the
in the universe what is our what is why
are extraterrestrial
interested in us well i think there's
been an interest in this planet for
millions of years okay i don't think
this is
new i think what became very much where
we became a planet of concern
like our state department has nations of
concern
is that in the 40s when we detonated the
first atomic bomb
that sent up a big red flag over this
planet going warning
this civilization can only be at a point
now where they can destroy all life on
this planet
but shortly thereafter we started going
into space
with sputnik we could become an
existential threat to other
peaceful planets some of whom do not
even have a concept of war and conflict
we've learned so i think that we were
viewed i mean it's funny because in the
media and hollywood and
and the internet and the whole ufo
subculture it's always you know
why are the aliens here and the
dangerous aliens and
fear fear fear i'm going no you got it
upside down dude
it's the other way around we're the
scary ones we're the ones who killed
hundreds of millions of people in the
last century in war
we're the ones who have thousands of
thermonuclear weapons
and we're the ones going into space with
weapon systems that are classified that
i know about and been briefed on
that are a thousand times worse than a
thermonuclear weapon
so this is the problem the problem is
that they know we have great potential
and beauty within humanity but they also
know that some of the
very powerful interests in the planet
you know what eisenhower
president eisenhower called the military
industrial complex
um have this sort of addiction
to viewing everything as a threat they
view anything they don't understand as a
threat and as one naval intelligence guy
told me
i asked him i said why are we targeting
these et
spacecraft and not in killing them
occasionally he says because
we view this as our planet if they don't
act as
our military's permission we're going to
kill them and shoot them down
so that is how primitive and stupid
the thinking is on that people make it
very complicated when i've been at the
pentagon
briefing three-star generals and people
like this
um that that is quite simply the mindset
so the general public doesn't understand
that
you know as as danny sheehan who's this
famous civil rights and constitutional
attorney said
if you're if you're a hammer the whole
world's a nail
so in this case if you know if you're a
military and you're oriented towards
everything being a threat that you don't
understand
then they're a threat in reality it's
the other way around the reason
these you see in the media coming out
through the senate intelligence
committee that they're trying to
posit this as a national security threat
because
the ets have been seen doing
surveillance over our nuclear facilities
and what have you
but that's not because they're a threat
if they wanted to take us out had been
done in 1945
i mean the technologies they have could
have terminated our civilization in an
instant
but they're not they're they have a
gandhian
like gandhi or christ or some
enlightenment they have that
level of pacifism simply because they
have pulled their punches waiting for us
we the people to resolve this problem
over the last 60 or 70 years so
that's why i left my medical career a
few years ago is to resolve this
crisis that is unacknowledged by the way
the other documentary on amazon prime
and other sites is called
unacknowledged and it stands for it's
the first word in a level of very
top-secret projects
known as unacknowledged special access
projects
those are the projects that are very
very secret that
i found out in the 90s when i was
briefing uh
bill clinton cia director and other
people like that
that they were being denied access to
those projects
and uh so most people don't realize i
have a home in washington a home out
here in charlottesville near the
university of virginia
and most people don't realize that most
of these politicians and even senior
military
are not briefed at that level of
clearance and
and that has created its own problems
because in the vacuum of that secrecy
all kinds of nutty crazy dangerous
things are going on
and there's nobody mining the store
there's nobody watching this
so that's that's why you know one of the
components of what i'm doing
is what we call the disclosure project
this year is the 20-year anniversary of
the big national press club event we did
in may
of 2001 where i had the first
22 of what is now 950
whistleblowers military intelligence
corporate people
who are giving us information documents
what have you
come forward in front of the whole world
about 800 900
million people saw that but in the in
the years since
unfortunately it's now gone in a good
way it's called mainstream
the whole this whole subject you see it
in the new york times cnn washington
post
but it's always got this narrative
attached to it that it's a
threat you know the whole hoax of an
alien
what what what i mean there's two parts
to it which is like
why is it hidden and why are they trying
to
perpetuate a fear-based uh
association with extraterrestrial and
put propaganda out there through
stories or movies or whatever why
first off why are they trying to promote
extraterrestrial in a negative way
that's a threat
well the main reason for that is
they it's money and power so if you
understand how
demagogues and uh big governmental
systems work
to control the public they do it mainly
through fear
and by the way organized religion has
done this as well this sort of
demagoguery
i grew up in north carolina in the south
in charlotte by the way great nascar
city as you know
oh yeah i lived in uh i lived in
mooresville when i was there
oh you're kidding me yeah oh i've never
been to i didn't car race because when
i was young we were too poor and when i
got older i got too busy
you need to take me to a nascar race no
problem i'll drive you there
oh that'd be awesome i'd be in good
hands
um so yeah i love cars by the way but so
um it's such a boy that way but i like
girls that like it too
you know my daughters by the way i
really really when i found out
you know that you wanted to do this
interview i was so excited because i
have these four daughters
who are very accomplished but have had
to go through a lot of
glass ceilings and stuff because they're
female
and um being the father of four
daughters i go yeah you go girl don't
listen to these people say you can't do
it
because you're a female i mean i just
think all that prejudice is such rubbish
and good for you
for doing what you have done but
honestly you're doing the exact same
thing in just a different arena
yeah you know while they're women in the
world and that's a dynamic
this is also a dynamic in the world
that's been repressed
and so i just don't understand why
it's it's well look you know we learned
as you know
from uh werner von braun who invented
the rocket
tradeoff hitler he got brought into
united states after world war ii and
became the foundation
of our aerospace program his spokeswoman
a woman one of the first women in
aerospace
carol rosen she's now in her late 70s
she on on his deathbed bernavon brown
begged her
to stop what they had a long-term plan
to do
and that is to enrich the
military-industrial complex
and to accumulate power around uniting
the world around quote
an alien threat that's a hoax and that's
been a 70-year project that we're trying
to divert
the other reason which is kind of
related
is that you know you and i are using
cars and jets and rockets
and our electricity is mostly coming
from fossil fuels or
gas or coal or what have you and we
haven't needed those technologies since
before i was born i was born in june of
1955
my senior naval intelligence advisor who
was the head
of the naval research labs in washington
as as the chief scientist not the
administrator
but the scientist was in a vault where
he saw the documents
that stated explicitly that we mastered
anti-gravity
gravity control in october of 1954
and that means that the energy system
that's
running these ufos is being pulled from
the
fabric of space called zero point and
the
propulsion isn't rockets or jets it's
uh electromagnetic vortices i'm not
going to get to the physics of it
because your audience will go to sleep
but we know it very well down to the
equations i have people on my team who
have this worked out to the equations
mathematically and so we haven't needed
any of this stuff that's destroying the
biosphere
carbon-based technologies but
that is hundreds of trillions of dollars
so it between the power of controlling
the narrative through fear and the money
and power
that goes along with oil and the petro
dollar and the
banking system based on the dollar which
is based on petroleum
etc and so on it's a very big deal you
know when i was at lawrence
rockefeller's ranch he was the scion of
the rockefeller family who ironically
was standard oil right that became
exxonmobil and all those
he told me you know he said look dr
greer this is a big deal because if this
comes out no aspect of life on earth
will be unaffected by it i said yes i
know it's why it has to happen
our civilization is stuck in the late
1800s paradigm
of oil and gas and linear electricity
lines
so we have a hundred years of lost
social progress
anti-poverty the environment is being
very strange because of this
and we're headed into a deep dive as you
know i mean an extinction level event is
possible
all because of greed and stupidity of
men
so i think that we have to realize that
these extraterrestrial civilizations to
pivot back to your question
earlier they're very
knowledgeable that most humans are not
corrupt that way
but they're also not informed so i've
sort of felt like somebody needed
to do something to get the information
out to the public and then the other
part of what i do which doesn't
get talked about much is that i provide
briefings to the president and ci
director
and members of congress even still i
mean i was i have a member of my team
that was running this information to
president trump and
and pence until they left office up
until a couple days before
we found out that that president trump
and pence had been brainwashed that the
aliens were a national security threat
that gave us the space force uh we now
have a new administration that i'm
doing some things with but you know i
had briefed
president biden when he was senate a
senator
and was chairman of the senate foreign
relations committee because
let's face it these are intelligent life
forms
that's the ultimate foreign relations
right it's not between us and russia
it's between earth and these other
civilizations
but that relationship has been totally
mismanaged
through the secrecy because most people
in government
know and very few people at the united
nations almost no one at the state
department knows anything about this
so the whole subject has been mismanaged
and so that's why i tell
i tell people the reason ce5 contact is
so important
is so that we become sort of citizen
ambassadors to those civilizations
and let them know that not everyone on
this planet is a
sociopath who wants to shoot them down
yeah well it's a direct i mean
it's it's because of the experience i
was just having a conversation with a
girl last night who's doing some really
progressive things when it comes to um
consciousness alignment with goddesses
and
genome and all kinds of things it's
again we're working into the quantum
into different fields to
access what's really available to us and
that's
that the real transformation
is the experience and so
ce5 which i did get the app and i'm like
wow there's a lot of people around here
in scottsdale that are
that have this app and are on the
program um
is that it's it's in that direct
experience that then you can start to
believe for yourself
right um what's going on what happens
for the world too
yeah well what i've always been curious
about too and maybe you can
maybe you know i would imagine you have
some insight is that
i'm curious if some of the activity that
we've seen in the sky sometimes
is actually us recreating from
our from crash sit
from from from from a from a from a
craft that's crashed
and we harvest the information from that
and reverse
engineer it for our own is is sometimes
what we see in the sky
us trying things out oh yes absolutely
remember what i just said since october
1954
the technologies were figured out
of how to move and create objects that
look like a ufo um or an et craft
and so one of the things we want to do
between now and june
when the director of national
intelligence has been ordered to issue a
report on this
is to do an expose of only this
agenda of falsely um
portraying the ets as a threat for for
greedy purposes
but also uh to show what my researchers
have we have
200 000 pages of documents and
blueprints and models 3d models
of man-made ufos that have come out of
the lockheed skunk works
my uncle's company northrop grumman
boeing
and other other classified contractors
with the us government
in these unacknowledged special access
projects ones that are deep black
super black and so yes what you're
saying is a
very important point and that is when
you see something you have to ask a
question
is it ours and it's classified
and they want you to think it's et or is
it extraterrestrial
now that's a deeper discussion on what
the distinctive qualities of that
are but i know people i've personally
because for 30 years i've led a team
a research team that's gone all over the
world to make contact
and we have hundreds of hours of videos
and photographs
uh some of which appear in this close
encounters of the fifth year yeah
there's a lot of footage in there that's
very very obvious and mind-blowing
yeah yeah including pictures of ets that
have been
right next to us in these circles we do
which is another whole discussion of the
way contact happens
but um one of the things that i i warn
people of
is that the reason the biggest secret
that they are not talking about the new
york times and cnn and the mainstream
media
isn't the fact that the ufos are real
everybody knows that
uh they're they're slow to the party
right they're not telling the public
that our classified projects have that
capability
and in fact they are overtly lying to
the president
these covert programs and to senators
at on the senate intelligence committee
i found
be call about that because they don't
want them to know these exist
because they want to use those to sort
of hoax
or fake alien attacks or alien events
uh which they've been doing for decades
for example
a lot of people have heard of these
alien abductions and mutilations
i personally have more than a dozen
people on my team who have been tactical
members
of military and corporate groups that
have been doing the abductions
they're using man-made ufos chemicals
and electronic warfare
to do this so everyone think oh that was
an alien encounter i said
no it wasn't they stage it very well
they're
extremely good at staging this and you
know one of the things you'll see in
close encounters of the fifth kind if
you look at that documentary it's a very
fast moving documentary
but there's an air force intelligence
official in there
that i asked this question to when i
interviewed him
he had been for a decade or two in in
the air force office of special
investigations
and he says oh yes we've been doing that
he just flat out admits it
but then he realizes he says something
he's showing he says but that's very
secret that's still very classified and
he backs out of it
the interview is fat the whole interview
is fascinating but we just have a little
clip in this documentary
so you can imagine in the 90s early 90s
when i had people who were
in these tactical teams
who were engaged in that kind of
deception i went oh boy
this is what's going on so a lot of
people say you know kind of false flags
kind of hooks when is that going to
happen
i said it started in the 50s so
whatever people google if you google
this subject
about 90 plus percent of it frankly i'm
a big skeptic
is nonsense that's been embedded in the
pop culture
because it scares people and if it
scares people
that is what they want they want to
brainwash the population
through fear prior to what's happening
this year and that's why i'm about to do
an expose we may between now and june
i'm trying to put some cosmonauts
together
and people from other countries in the
us as well as carol rosin
who worked with vernavon brown and do
another
event where we get this out to the
public so they're not
it's like the who after the vietnam war
we won't be fooled again you know that
song
well we were fold again guess what the
iraq war
was all based on false intelligence that
was host
that dick cheney and his people got to
colin powell colin powell was a victim
he goes to the united nations presents
all this
afterwards he admitted that he was
played like a fiddle
by these intelligence folks and that
saddam hussein didn't have any of those
weapons
but a million dead people later and two
trillion dollars
later and a horrible war that's busted
up the middle east and syria
later so that is what they're planning
to do on the
ufo and et subject that we have to avert
we have to stop
it's a house of cards because that's
what's happening is that as we
start to realize if one thing if they've
lied about one thing what else are they
lying about so if they're
doing false flags for as ufos or
extraterrestrial interaction
that's a that's a false flag and that's
that's a lie what else have they done
that is in that same
vein and so it's in this time that we
are
bursting the bubble on all the stiff
stuff and but what i
can not for the life of me figure out is
how i mean look it is dissolving
the veil is getting thinner between
reality and
the um movie they've been playing for us
right the truman show
the truman show oh my god i was watching
the truman show a few weeks back and i
was like
i'm watching a documentary called the
truman show and then i watched him
in the matrix which is also another
documentary um
but i just don't get how they can keep
it hidden
well they hide it in plain sight back in
the early 90s after i'd briefed the cia
director i had a guy who was on the
committee dealing with the secrecy
that had been lying to president clinton
uh and he said look we just hide this in
plain sight we put this out there
in a way that is the public is aware of
it
i mean i think after pornography the
number one search thing on the internet
or ufos
but the problem is is that they attach
the false narrative to it
so it's sort of like the way counter
intelligence works and
false information works you put a little
bit of truth at the center of it
like those tic tac those craft that our
navy jets chased off the coast of
california
it's been on all the news for the last
two or three years the pentagon has
affirmed that those are real ufos
but they attach in every article this
statement
that it's a national security threat so
they're they're now gone from pop
culture and movies in hollywood
and the ufo subculture sort of fringe to
the mainstream
media and now from the director of
national intelligence
due in june is this report that was
ordered in the covid bill
signed in december 27th they have 180
180 days to get that out so i'm trying
to get
more of this information out including
showing the models
and the aircraft that were developed
through my uncle's company
and lockheed skunk works back in the 50s
60s 70s
and they continue to be developed that
have been kind of hoaxing events
so that's that's really really important
and
in the meanwhile what the average person
can do
is form a a little ce5 contact team
one of the interesting things about this
app we just released is that it has a um
a networking feature so you can see
who's around you like in scottsdale or
la or
london or whatever and you can kind of
it's kind of like a dating app for
cosmos but where you can
meet other people and do these these
protocols so you're not by yourself
um and even you can do it remotely
through to zoom and things but we're
having people
all over the world have amazing contact
experiences we had a
truck driver from croatia
who wrote into the website and my wife
monitors it
the website we don't have any staff by
the way don't get grandiose
my wife and i have a little corner of
our living room and volunteers we have
no offices no staff everything
we crowdfunded these documentaries
through donations
um nobody's ever helped us we just put
the information out it's just a labor of
love
but she'll get these emails from people
and there's this truck driver in croatia
who pulled over late at night in the
mountains and he had the app
the ce5 contact app and was doing the
the techniques and the meditation
suddenly this et craft pops
right beside his truck on the left and
comes and floats over the front of it
and then vanishes sort of letting them
know him know
we got your signal and we're here thank
you know there's just an acknowledgment
and this was a truck driver i mean it
wasn't like it was like
guru swami shivananda or something you
know this is like
a dude driving a truck all right through
the mountains
so i tell people that these this
capability that we have within us the
light
of consciousness is the birthright of
every single human
but it's also the birthright and present
in every e.t
because they're conscious and sentient
and since they have technologies that we
haven't yet developed at least
not in the covert world i mean not the
overt world
you know they exist in classified
projects that interface with
consciousness and thought
that's why these protocols work as sort
of far out as it sounds it sounds really
far out
until you take a a few hours and do a
deep dive
into the science behind what has been
already done
at princeton and other universities yeah
about consciousness and the fact that
the conscious field
is sort of everywhere omnipresent and
can be
interfaced with by humans and can be
measured
so those are early studies but it just
means that
we're really on to a whole new science
here
dealing with consciousness and in its
application sort of deep spirituality
not necessarily organized religion but
spirituality on a deep level
and where physics where physics and
and spirituality come together it's
really quite amazing
yeah it is and i agree
who is really controlling this narrative
because it seems like when you dive into
enough of this stuff you start to
understand that like
there's a lot of levels above what we
think's in charge
and so it feels like
it feels like whoever is in control at
the tippy top
is is the place to go because clearly
it's not happening at the level we're at
there's a committee i know a number of
the members of it called
uh it's had various names over the years
back in the 40s 50s it was called mj12
um majority 12 a group of men that were
in charge of this issue it's
one of the names in the 90s i have a
document
that was given to me that's classified
that i published there's a book called
unacknowledged that has this document in
it
um called magic m-a-j-i-c
what it stands for is the majority
intelligence committee and it's a group
of people who deal with this but they
have they're sort of permanently in the
system
and have activities that are above what
are usually told to a president or a
senator or a member of the congress
in fact i mean to give you an idea how
secret this is
i spent a couple of hours um two or
three hours
and i brought astronaut uh edgar
mitchell with me to the pentagon for
this and
because he was i was teaching him about
this issue back in
97 and the man who was the head of
intelligence
for the joint chiefs of staff admiral
tom wilson
we had gotten a document to him that had
a lot of the code names that i have for
these projects and where they are
which facilities which companies i have
all this information
it's in the book unacknowledged for
anyone wants to read it i've updated it
since then
but that admiral
who they have to understand this is the
man in charge of doing the intelligence
briefings for the joint chiefs of staff
the united states pentagon
military he had been denied access
to those projects and when he started
pushing on it he was overtly threatened
until they would demote him take a star
off of his lapel
if he kept pushing so by the time i got
to the briefing in person this is a
document i sent ahead of time
he was furious and scared
and it was supposed to be a 45-minute
stand-up briefing that i was doing
for this admiral and it ended up going
up for two or three hours
because uh it was so much information
and it was so
important to him but he was really
afraid because he said look i have this
responsibility
he says who else have you briefed who
have been denied access to the projects
i said well the president the cia
director members of the senate
intelligence committee it's members of
the foreign relations committee
and he was horrified i said yes this is
sort of a subterranean
highly classified group that does what
they damn well wish
and the reason i ended up briefing the
cia director for
mr clinton for president clinton in 93
a few months after he took office was
because
clinton had ordered the cia director and
some people the department of justice
that he was friends with webster hubble
and others to look into this
and they couldn't get anything and they
knew they were being lied to
so they knew i had collected information
but more importantly the people who set
up the meeting knew that my
team had successfully made direct
contact with the et's
that we'd figured out the sort of
rosetta stone of how to communicate
using consciousness and thought and
these techniques
so i go up there with my wife i'm a
young doctor in my 30s rattling around
in an emergency department and so i'm
doing this sort of shuttle diplomacy as
it were
up to dc raising four daughters and
being an emergency doctor taking care of
horrific trauma
but i go now i'm into real trauma
because i'm now
sitting here with the director of the
cia and i didn't believe it at first i
thought he was
lying when i got the letter from his
people
but it turned out he was denied access
and this is a very dangerous thing
so later i found out from someone on the
committee this so-called
magic mhaic group that the president
doesn't need to know and we're not going
to tell him anything they just
this person just flat out told me he he
said that those people come every four
to eight years we tell them what we want
to tell them
and the rest we just don't tell them
anything
so this was something that i realized at
that point that we're dealing with an
unconstitutional criminal enterprise
and that's when i went through the
looking class that's when it got really
rough
um and of course this is a 30-year
journey i'm giving you a really quick
kind of cliff notes for but it was it
was scary
frankly i mean to do i don't know if you
can imagine being younger than you are
being responsible for briefing the cia
director and find out gee
you know we don't know anything because
this group is lying to us so that sort
of upended my whole world view of
politics government civics all that
well definitely
an aspect of all of this is
your safety oh i don't care about that
they want to kill me kill me
maybe that's why they haven't right
because you just don't let that into
your consciousness says
i'm not afraid of it you know you know
you know it's funny that the
head of army intelligence in 1992
when he found out what we were doing he
was so angry
he threatened me with i took me to a
hotel room till late in
2 30 in the morning with the nsa
national security agency guy and some
other
spooks and he says who hell do you think
you are
i said well i'm a free citizen of the
earth and of the cosmos and
we're making contact he says you're not
cleared i said i don't need your
clearance or permission
so we went mano amano and i'm a nice guy
until you challenge me and i'm going to
let you out
so here we go so we go mano amano with
this guy
yeah i am sort of grew up in the south
and in a way that was rough and tumble
and i said ah you don't you know you're
afraid of you i deal with people coming
to the er
with automatic weapons in my face you
think i'm afraid of you
so and then i turned to him i said look
when i was 17 i died
i know there is no death i know that
what is within me and within all of us
goes on forever and is infinite
and eternal and therefore
if you want to kill me go ahead but i'll
be more trouble to you on the other side
and he knows
he knew
so that happened and then about a month
later
he came to an event that astronaut brian
o'leary
uh and i had organized up in uh
colorado near uh estes park in the
rockies
and he came he offered me personally
2 billion with a b billion dollars if i
would be quiet
and i said no i can't be bought off and
you're not going to buy me or scare me
so he goes behind my back to my wife who
is this wonderful
you know sort of a jewish doctor's
daughter who is sort of epitomizes no
bless oblige
very kind in this peace corps they
called her saint m because she's so
kindly
but and and she said oh he's such a nice
man i said no he's a devil with fork
tongue
because my my grandmother was cherokee
native american
oh yeah a little bit of that too oh cool
awesome
and so i said no i said we're not gonna
we're not getting in bed with these
crooks and we're not gonna be scared of
them
but yeah and that was when a billion
dollars was a lot of money now
of course everybody in silicon valley
makes a billion dollars a week but wow
um there are a lot of money but well i'm
joking but i just said
how corrupt is that now this gets into a
big
problem uh danica is that there are
people
when they start getting close to the
truth
and they think they could be a little
too much trouble
like i was they are either
threatened or they are given a buyout
offer be quiet
do what we tell you to do and there'll
be a fund in some country
that you can use maybe not two billion
but tens of millions
it's corruption on a really large scale
and you know i met with a man in
phoenix back in 93
who said you know we have provided over
10 million dollars to at least 10 000
people
or more to secure their cooperation on
the secrecy
that was in 93 and this was a member of
this committee i'm referring to
so between the threats and the
corruption and bribes
this is i mean you know people think
watergate was a scandal or a wrong
contra
this is the biggest scandal in the
history of the united states
period and that's why i'm the most hated
person in washington and the most hated
person in the mainstream media because
as you know from seeing close encounters
to the fifth kind
danny sheehan who represented the new
york times
against the pentagon and during the
pentagon papers the vietnam war
he saw a document that listed 42 editors
and senior people on media around the
world
that were on the payroll of the cia
but had cover working as an editor here
and there
so this is another reason why social
media platforms
and shows like yourself are so important
because
i am completely blacklisted from most of
those
outlets because i'm not going to just
say gee this is a uap
a stupid fake term um
we don't know what it is we don't know
where they come from and
cover up the fact that our classified
aerospace programs
that my uncle were for northrop grumman
the biggest ones one of the biggest that
we have these technologies that would
save the world's environment you talk
about the ultimate green new deal
it's bringing these technologies out you
don't need a windmill or solar farm
if something that is is two feet by two
feet would run
your entire building with no energy cost
day and night
well i mean there's of course the whole
nikola tesla
thing and exactly how did how did he die
and
why are we not using free energy and
you know i mean that's it's been going
on forever we wouldn't have to look at
stupid power lines along the streets and
wreck our view and
you know waste a ton of it's just
it's just pointless technology it is
pointless and even solar
and wind which of course at least don't
pollute they are
don't have the en energy density to run
eight billion
people on this planet in enough time we
have got to bring these new technologies
out
that's a long-term goal of mine is to
put together enough
people who begin to understand this so
we start an
open source research and development lab
that brings these technologies out
i've got a computer disk with hundreds
of pages
of confiscated patents related to this
that go back
a hundred years that was given to me by
a cie contact
but you've got to have a lab build these
things up but you know we have it
but that's your talking now not
crowdfunding i think we crowdfunded
900 000 for close encounters of the
fifth kind
and we the distributor won't pay for any
of the publicity either
so we had to pay for the production and
the publicity
and so we used up all that money but i
don't have enough ability to get tens of
millions of dollars put together
to start a serious high energy physics
research and development program
that's going to be way beyond my
capability as a retired
doctor you know i don't have that
there'd be some people out there though
that would be an alliance with your
mission
and truth and i think they're coming out
in spades more and more whether they're
even because again it's that blending of
science and spirituality and so it's
like
you know whether they're someone like
that works more on the bio
biofarming bio hacking like you name it
there's people that i
i i feel that i feel that there be
people that be willing to get behind
this
and so what that leads to is a question
of like
what's the tipping point like what's
that point in time
where this becomes mainstream
believed and a
real thing in this world instead of just
speculation curiosity no it should have
happened
decades ago and i was sitting at
senator barry goldwater's house who
lived right near you in paradise valley
back in the 90 he was the senior senator
republican from
arizona who ran in 1964 for president
when i was at his home he was in his 80s
and retired and he told me some amazing
stories
and he said you know she's my language
she said it was a goddamn mistake then
and a goddamn mistake now that this was
ever kept secret
but when he tried to find out about it
because he had heard rumors about this
subject through air force buddies
he was a air force a general in the air
force reserves
he turned to general curtis lemay
who is in charge a chief of staff of the
air force back then
and he said curtis i'd like to be shown
the blue room
at wright-patterson air force base where
the early et materials that we captured
were being stored
and lemay i mean this is from barry
goldwater's lips to my ears
turned to curtis curtis may turn to
barry goldwater and said
god damn it barry i can't even get into
that area anymore
and if you ever asked me about this
again
i will personally see that you are
court-martialed
out of the air force this to a senior
u.s senator
now that people hearing what i just said
think about who
senator goldwater was google him if you
don't have don't remember your history
books
i met with this man he says absolutely
he was denied access
even though he was head of the
republican party ran for
president lost at lyndon johnson
and was a senior senator in on armed
services and all these and
was a general in the air force reserves
didn't matter and he had a very close
relationship with general lemay
who unfortunately became famous for
recommending that we drop nuclear
weapons in vietnam
which we didn't thankfully but the
my point is is that even general lemay
at a certain point got denied access
to these projects that is how wrapped up
this is you and i have a beautiful
letter from
senator goldwater wishing hoping that we
can succeed in doing this
but he was not able to penetrate that
system even given his
bona fides how do you get access to this
information in these people
it's just it's sort of the mysterious
how it happens but
i think part of it is that
people know that i'm very serious person
about this
i have the largest archive in the world
i don't trade in internet rumors i
only talk about actionable intelligence
from direct
sources not second hand third and fourth
hand
um and and i and it's very hard to do
that because the rumor mill on this
subject is rumors of rumors of rumors
and that's what most programming
internet and shows
are usually and i kind of steer clear of
that
because i can't afford that uh and
that's why you know i've been invited to
to meet with a lot of world leaders and
ministers of defense
and um people and then the the military
and intelligence and corporate people
who are in these classified projects
continue every week or two there's a new
one who reaches out to me
most of them are terrified to come out
publicly
but i if you go to my youtube channel
you can drop a link
i have something like 70 of these top
secret people's
testimonies on my youtube channel now i
don't have that many people i have like
340
000 followers because we don't have a
social media team we don't have a
publicity
publicist we don't we don't have
anything i mean we're like pathetic
really
but we do what we can my wife is 72 now
and we just sit in the corner of our
living room and try to fight the fight
but
um you know we have great volunteers but
we don't have any
institutional support or help and most
people don't understand that there's
a youtube channel there with dozens of
top secret bona fide people
i mean they do a really good job with
algorithms and controlling and shutting
things down
that you know your youtube look i watch
youtube i just watch
information i mean like i could just do
i have to show because i i'm already
consuming information so sometimes
i watch a show like yours and i'm like
let's see if he'll talk to me and
sometimes
we get an interview and then i learn
about them but either way i'm assuming
information and so um
which leads me to a curious question and
it kind of like
links up a little bit with potential and
extraterrestrial of an extraterrestrial
but
um and it's this idea or that well it's
this direction we're going as a
as a civilization with a.i and
then the sort of and again like i'm not
by any means as educated as you are on
all this but then there's
there's conversations around if
there is a sort of
if extraterrestrials are here negative
thought form extraterrestrials
either feeding off of our negative
energy and getting
getting energy from us as we are some
sort of a
i mean it's really in the matrix
actually where we are
we are sourcing energy for them i mean
the way that we the amount of energy
that we create as a being is
is really extremely high um
or if you know if there's i mean of
course then you can go down even further
rabbit holes on
shape shifters and inner earth beings
and you know reptilians and you know
there's a million different directions
you could go with this but
most of which is most of which is
rubbish so let me
kind of provide some clarity to all that
thank you
there are three categories of things
people are talking about
as if it is one one is
actual extraterrestrial biological
entities evens
from other star systems that have craft
etc
okay 100 they're not hostile 100 percent
they're peaceful
100 percent they're way more advanced
than we are socially in every other way
then there are the man-made phenomena
man-made
ufos and man-made electronic systems
that simulate et and also
things from other dimensions like
stranger things montauk
then you have actual intelligences
and beings that are from another
dimension but are not
extraterrestrial got it okay
now what is happening with i call it
cosmological indigestion
it's all getting mixed up is that
those all those categories because of a
lack of knowledge and discernment and
education
it's not you know are being all mixed
together and conflated as one
thing that's very dangerous actually and
the intelligence community
loves it because they love for people to
be confused
and deceived and they'd love for people
to believe
that some of these et's are these
malevolent
negative energy sucking things like an
incubus or something
um that we should be terrified of
because that justifies
the war effort that justifies the
weapons in space
so this confusion is
deliberate it's been fostered
through counterintelligence operatives
in the society
and one of the most difficult things
that i encounter all the time
is untangling for people this
cosmological confusion so now it gets a
little more nuanced
when you begin to understand that from
the late 50s forward
the intelligence community had
electronic devices
that could activate through other
dimensions some of these
intelligences that are not e.t
but are kind of spooky like the series
stranger things a lot
a lot of these x-files those guys just
depict my brain
for stuff for sure it all got made into
hollywood you know
stuff sensational stuff but there's a
core of it that's true
and i have a member of my team who is a
lockheed
engineer who is at the cube which is the
big
underground research facility in the
high desert of california for lockheed's
skunk works where he says oh yeah we had
the electronics well we could put
someone in a room and go
and with electronic headset go into
these other dimensions not
extraterrestrial
and pull into 3d these spooky creatures
now this sounds like something out of
stranger things
i've been talking about this for about
20 years and most people listen they go
wwtf is he serious i am serious
this entire subject is unfortunately
more nuanced than complex
but they like for people to kind of lump
it all together
because by lumping it all together you
can then say
see some of these ets are scary
and we need a defense system in space so
we can make a few trillion more dollars
etc and so on so people have to
understand how
information and disinformation is
embedded
with a strategic objective i really need
to do an entire course on counter
intelligence and disinformation
which i've just become somewhat of a
specialist in
unfortunately um just by virtue of being
who
and kind of what i am do that confuse or
help
with your oh that's that makes sense i
mean i what i'm understanding is part of
the
negative energies that would come
through are are really honestly more
spirit they're more
sort of they're interdimensional their
inner dimension they're dimensional
they're from a lower
they're from other dimensions that are
coming through us and
um they come through and from my
understanding in
lower states of being which are through
negativity and
fear and lower frequencies that's the
only way they can sort of take root
is through the liver well you know
interesting when i was at the vatican
some years ago there was a a senior
theologian for pope john paul that i was
at his apartments overlooking
saint peter's and he he we start we have
this conversation i interviewed him we
have a big interview with him it's in
italian which
i can't understand but if we had someone
translate it we could put it out
but anyway um what's interesting is that
when our conversation he wouldn't do the
interview in english because his english
wasn't proficient enough but in
conversation he would
speak with me and he said um
we started talking about this issue
exactly what you brought up
and he says yes he says well neither
angels
nor demons require flying saucers
and he started laughing now he was the
senior theologian and demonologist for
the pope
at the vatican so we had this amazing
conversation where he clearly understood
the difference between these sort of
spooky things from other dimensions
versus
humans versus interstellar
planetary civilizations that are
extraterrestrial
now the reason they're easily confused i
want to take it one more little notch i
hope i don't lose your your audience
no you're not losing me if you're going
from one star system to another
through vastness of space you cannot do
it at the speed of light
it would take you millions of years
therefore
those spacecraft and everyone on it
through electronics we understand now
very high voltage resonant systems
harmonic
resonance systems drop out of linear
space time
and traverse through other dimensions
to go from you know a million light
years
here and here is really right here
because of what's called entanglement in
physics
but they're not doing it on a particle
level of physics which you can read
about
they're doing it with whole spacecraft
and everyone on board but because
they can go through these other
dimensions they can remain in those
dimensions while they're outside
your back door and all you'll see is a
sphere or an orb
now there could be things from other
dimensions that might look like an orb
where do you how do you know the
difference if you have to be trained
and that's what i train people to do i
do these week-long expeditions out in
the desert we
went out actually to arizona many years
are you doing any more can i come
well you know since last march when they
shut the planet down because of covid we
haven't organized any of those i did
i did one for several days up in joshua
tree national park with with demi lovato
and some of her friends and my senior
team we had amazing things happen
we had craft right above us up here i
could probably collect a few people that
would be very interested in very
interesting people we should do that we
should do it with a bunch of influencers
who can kind of get the word out
oh i could 100 put that together
oh that'd be great we should do that be
so much fun um
because there are beautiful places to do
it once it warms up a bit
you have to be careful at night we you
know one time we were at joshua tree and
it was like 18 degrees at night we had
no idea and people were freezing
because you're out there for like six
hours at night oh yeah
well that's okay we i think that we
could figure out how to stay warm plus
actually i just did an interview for
wine so it's like sitting here so i'd be
like
some of that you know that's right there
you go
we find ways i call that after we do our
like formal
project at the end we do a babitas and
conviviality and have a little party at
the end
that's fun demi thought it was hilarious
because i'm i'm a bit of a wild man
party animal
more yeah an extremist yeah
you do what i do you got to cut loose
yeah 100 life is about balance it's it's
absolutely about balance um what i mean
like what's your hope like what i mean
in your
lifetime like what what what are you
hoping to accomplish
because i want to help like i totally
believe in this stuff too
and you know i i have more examples of
the consciousness side of things and
connecting energetically
uh entanglement wise through
consciousness to
my higher self but other beings as well
and having communication
and getting information and so like they
all thread into the same
sort of thing and i've been meeting some
really fascinating people and
and you know we basically are like okay
so we
are ancient uh friends and we come from
this star system
and um but i i just think that if we're
going to take the next step
is as a civilization we can't improv we
can't
try and fix or change what's
going on with the old world we just have
to make a new one
correct and as einstein said no problem
was ever solved
from the level of consciousness that
created it
we have to be in a higher level and yes
one thing that everyone can
do is is to help us get this information
out to their
social media followers if you can help
us with that
it's really all networking since you
know we really don't have
a budget of any consequence or what have
you it's all just
person-to-person networking and that's
how we've reached i mean
unacknowledged that documentary was
eventually seen
by about 650 million people oh i saw it
years ago i saw it
yeah and so that's how we're doing this
just little by little
you know to the extent we have but
people who can get the word out and
i'm going to i'm going to start a um
a 10 part they're short 30 minute shows
on a sort of a a consciousness based
uh tv network called gaia tv i'm gonna
start
my own program starting in uh
we're gonna it should come out this
summer i think
and um you should interview me you
should be the guy
the host that interviews me i'd love to
it would be so cool yeah it's right
there in boulder
anyway um i was just talking to the
producer last night uh about this so
uh and that'll be great because we'll be
over 10
30 minutes segments we'll be able to go
pretty deeply
in a way that will reach you know a fair
number of people that way
um and so that's what i'm just trying to
look for you know how do i i get this
information out
uh in a way that's increasingly deep you
know because
it's one thing to say well the ufos are
real but we don't know what they are
is this thing say well once you find out
what they are and they're
multiple sources man-made and e.t
what are you going to do uh now what are
we going to do when we grow up well we
need to make contact with them
but since the government's so
dysfunctional i'm
i'm just down the road from thomas
jefferson's house monticello and i go
well it's we the people
right so i believe
i believe in people power we are the
power
yes one person cannot change everything
it's the collect
yeah no i think people increasingly are
awakening to that i
i did a clubhouse interview um oh cool
yeah i've got
that app too oh well we should follow
each other on it i didn't know anything
about it until a couple weeks ago but um
i was on a couple days after elon musk
and we had like
three times as many people in my room as
he did and it was so
exciting but what i what i was saying in
that is you know it
you're there's no timeline i think we
went until four or five in the morning
east coast time
and uh it was kind of crazy but um
it was that many people maybe 8 000
people but what what
what i shared was that you know and
i'm dating myself here but when i was in
high school
in north carolina and charlotte um
i had an african-american girlfriend
and which not cool in 1972 and 73 this
will get you killed
um and i was run over i was hit by a car
bicycling to school by a bunch of
racists who were screaming
inward lover at me and all this i was
very hated
for having an african-american
girlfriend who is wonderful
but you know and i tell people what is
this
constant evolution in humanity to go
beyond
our divisions and our tribalism
whether it be homophobia misogyny
prejudice against one ethnic or
religious group or anti-semitism
or racism now what the intelligence
community is very good at doing
is presenting some of the et's as the
next
race we have to fight it's like cowboys
and indians in space
and that's they're playing on human
weakness
to be afraid of the unknown that's the
roots of racism they're different from
us
they're not part of our tribe therefore
we're going to fight them
and this this is a deep discussion we're
getting into here
where in order to transcend that to go
beyond
that we have to go into an understanding
of what is the color of conscious spirit
right it's not black it's not white it's
not gay it's not straight it's not
this is not that it's not human it's not
e.t it's universal
yeah and see that is at its root the
solution
to this endless de balkanization
and division that sets one group against
another and another group against
another
this gone forever it's been going on for
thousands of years on this planet
but it can't go on much longer when you
start
then expanding that racist paradigm
to an interstellar one because now
you're talking about
war of the worlds right you're talking
about world war three so
that's what we have to wait awaken to
and in a way this sounds very
philosophical but it's actually very
practical
we have to have a paradigm commensurate
with the time we live in and we're
living in an interstellar moment
even if it's unacknowledged and and so
we have to develop a paradigm
that goes beyond just our own human
concepts and so it you know
if we've got to go beyond just the
concepts of one group of humanity
oppressing another
we have people in the intelligence
community trying to set up a new boogie
man
similar to how adolf hitler set up the
jews and gay people and intellectuals
and threw them into ovens
well that's what these people really are
i don't use this word
promiscuously uh fascists and
and they want everyone to be at each
other's throat in
endless war and endless war and endless
war well the only way we're going to
break out of that cycle in my opinion
is that we realize what is really deep
within us that's profoundly
unifying and that is this deeper state
of
pure consciousness yeah
well maybe i'll ask the final question
then that
um you can give me your perspective on
it
uh what are we here for
i think we're here to carry forward
a really ever advancing civilization
that becomes peaceful interstellar
but is also the womb earth is a female
conscious being becomes the womb of the
evolution
of humanity in higher states of
consciousness and enlightenment
and that goes on forever and eventually
we humans will become extraterrestrials
to other worlds
educating and advancing that i see this
as a
as a motif that goes on forever and ever
and that's part of the big play and
display of creation and the creator
of the drop each of us being drops
returning to the ocean forever and ever
yeah
i uh two things one i i have heard that
i've heard that um there
are extraterrestrial guiding us
with certain like i mean look i'm
getting out there but why not
what we're talking about is pretty out
there i have
i exist in other and other planetary
systems in other dimensions
i have i have i have
guides that are from other dimensions
helping me
and that's happening all across the
world and that they're here to help
guide us
into um the continuing to be the next
state of consciousness and when we
finally become a peaceful planet then
just like you said i heard
that we become the next
group of extraterrestrial that then go
into other planetary systems
and help guide them through their
evolution
to um it's beyond enlightenment
it's oneness it's it's a unity it's a
it's a drop in the ocean right where we
return back to consciousness
i watched this beautiful um i watched
this
show called the good place i don't know
if you've ever seen it but it's about
going to the good
place or the bad place and uh sorry if
you haven't seen it but want to but at
the end of it
someone there's there's a couple and he
decides that he wants to leave
and return back to that field and
you now in the good place have this
option to leave where they didn't before
but anyway that's part of the show
and anyway he was describing to his his
partner
his girlfriend i don't think they were
married in the show he was explaining
what it was like and he said you imagine
the ocean
and it's a wave and it's a wave and it
comes to the shore and then it crashes
and then it just returns to the ocean
it's still
the wave was there it just looks
different now and it's part of the ocean
so it never
leaves and i thought that was just such
like a really beautiful way of thinking
about our
existence as humans yes um and we are
that's what we really are and we can
choose to view and
we can connect only as that ripple or
wave
our individuality or we can also
simultaneously be aware of the ocean
that we actually are part of
and that's what this expanded state of
consciousness and meditative state
delivers you to that's what i
experienced when i died
that's what i experienced when i go into
deep meditation
and it's um i still do it i train people
in these meditation
uh techniques and part of the
people don't realize when they go on one
of these ce5 contact
expeditions everyone thinks they're
going out there to
watch and see a ufo i said well that
happens we connect with those
after we've done this other work where
we understand how to become the ocean
and operate as ourself individually
at the same time we're aware of the
ocean it's simultaneous
and that's cosmic consciousness so
that's what you know when i was 17
18 experienced and got introduced to
and became your life's work it's
beautiful work
yeah yeah it became your life's work
that's thank you so much for
your transparency and your honesty and i
know that you
you know don't care because you've gone
through things but look you're bravery i
mean these are things that most people
just decide to take the 2 billion
or they decide you know what my my
safety is more important than this i'll
just you know
you know we'll just wait until the next
life maybe or these are probably people
that don't think they have a next life
and you know i really appreciate it and
your work is changing the world thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click
on the subscribe button